le crime organisé s'est transformée à
montréal au cours des dernières
décennies
avant c'était les stupéfiants qui domine
et les activités criminelles maintenant
on ajoute la fraude la traite de
personnes et les armes à feu régnaient
jadis
avec les armes à feu
les fusillades sont presque quotidiennes
à montréal et certaines se passe en
plein jour la phase aller gagnent leurs
crimes nazis extraire du sud parce que
c'est inquiétant absolument
il y avait tant le portrait de la
criminalité était relativement simple
lorsqu'on parlait de gangs de rue la
rivalité est essentiellement entre les
blogs aussi appelé les rouges à ceux ci
au quartier de montréal-nord et les
crips aussi appelé les bleus à ceux ci
au quartier de saint-michel vingt ans
plus tard le portrait de la criminalité
dans la métropole est loin d'être simple
je pourrais faire une nomenclature des
des gangs de rue criminel qu'on connaît
puis de mayom dans un discours très
ferme à l'or illégal secret et se
dissout nous change complètement non
accès difficile de vous donner un
chiffre sur le nombre de gains ce qui
est nouveau la collaboration entre les
motards la mafia et les gangs de rue à
bâle pour justement d'un seul chef qui
dit chez troupes et bien d'un modèle
d'affaires alors déjà que se regroupent
à 100 dans un but commun qui a puni
toutefois deux gangs de rue semble se
livrer une guerre sans merci les points
fait beau et cette rivière des prairies
ils les ont 43 de montréal nord rui
focus
on retrouve ces réseaux sociaux
en effet ces deux groupes utilisent la
musique est grave pour s'afficher et
s'invectivent et les armes sont souvent
omniprésente et les propos menaçants
hockey par exemple ce rappeur associé au
profit de boys montre fièrement sa
voiture criblée de balles dans ses
vidéos qui
y amène la pièce à perdre
la vie de tous les jours
une pièce de théâtre sanglante puisque
plusieurs d'entre eux ont été tués
dernièrement dont le rappeur mc a zo
assassiné en plein jour dans le quartier
rivière des prairies
la viola fameux sentiment d'impunité
mélanger avec la glorification jetant
rousseau rien contre ce coup d'avoir un
arme à feu la faire des clips de montrer
notre supérieur
il en appelle à la presse
les enquêtes sont nombreuses complexes
et surtout difficile
les moins jeunes ce matin par arme à feu
c'est une victime aujourd'hui collabos
pack new et le lendemain on broadway et
la vengeance bien avec le risque
d'atteindre des personnes innocentes
comme la jeune myriam badaoui tué lors
d'une fusillade c'est léonard en février
dernier le soir dit que j'arrêtais
chaussures mauvaise place au mauvais
moment
c'est très fort cher je peux vous
garantir que c'est pour la réponse
donnée
en acceptant le commandant renou insiste
quand même sur le fait que montréal
demeure une ville sécuritaire et les
effectifs policiers sont suffisants
bonjour mon lit pour demander à ce
citoyen de ne pas voir par une fois
qu'on fait bien ensemble on va peut-être
changer on va peut-être réaliser quelque
chose d'inimaginable finale inversé la
vapeur ça côté